love at first as a feeling but it  becomes a choice at some point  what are your parents what kind of  advice do your parents give because i  feel like they're good  yeah um my parents give great advice um  my dad told me  to leave that i didn't take a lot of it  um the first time he broke up with me i  think like they told me to like  he's like why would you he asked me if i  was um if i liked torture my dad he was  like he's spreading it's interesting  he's like he keeps breaking up with you  and you keep going back you could be a  masochist  do you like torture um  yeah because it would upset you  yeah um  i'm trying to think  my mom told me to find a guy that loves  you more than you love him which is very  opposite of what the man of sphere says  no it's not no  no in terms of the way men love  that's the way men love  i i think women